[MUSIC PLAYING]
AREZOO RIAHI: Women
around the world
have made remarkable strides,
socially, economically,
academically.
However, there is
still a ways to go.
Cultural barriers hinder
women's presence and advancement
in the fields of science,
tech, engineering, and math.
And this is happening
here in our own backyard,
in Silicon Valley.
But it's nothing compared to
what is happening in the Middle
East and North Africa.
As director of TechWomen,
I have the privilege
to work with the very
women who are working
to solve these challenges.
I think we started
a little early,
I'm going to wait for
my slides to catch up.
The root cause this is
not a lack of education.
In fact, more women
enroll in science and tech
related degrees than men.
The problem is that women
are simply not getting hired.
Unemployment is high, and
when positions are available,
they're going to the men.
In the Middle East, less
than one third of women
participate in the
workforce, according
to the World Bank, which is
the lowest among all regions.
And if women aren't working,
everyone-- their families,
their businesses, and
their communities--
are missing out
on a contribution
of a key demographic.
I'm sorry, where are the
slid-- oh, here we go.
OK.
I'm still going to stand here.
This is our first Ignite talk.
Ha, ha.
OK, so I was in Jordan
a few weeks ago,
and the country is facing
serious challenges.
With so many refugees from
neighboring countries,
their infrastructure cannot
accommodate the influx
of people.
And as you can imagine,
fixing the gender gap
is just not at the top
of their priority list.
And that's why we go
to places like Jordan.
We meet with girls, and we
inspire them to pursue careers
in science and tech.
We feel this is a
way for them to build
a bright future for
themselves, and we
do everything we can to
support them to be successful.
And the good news is that
despite what I just described,
there's a lot happening in
Jordan's vibrant capital
of Amman.
Here's a photo of
their business park.
It's become the
hub for innovation,
and it's a place for thought
leaders come together.
As you can see,
Google Developers
have had an event there,
just a few years back.
And here's where TechWomen
has made an impact.
Meet Hannan.
She is a TechWomen
alumni from 2013
who works at the
business park, where
she launched a startup to teach
kids as young as 8 how to code.
This year 30 schools will
implement her curriculum
for 40,000 students.
And this is Afnan.
She participated in a
program five years ago,
and came home to launch
a program teaching kids
about hardware and robotics.
And they're just two examples
of alumni going home and making
a difference.
And it is critical for
that, because in order
to effect real
change, it needs to be
done by the people
who are living
in those very communities.
We need to have women to
serve as positive role models
and to encourage girls to
pursue careers, and inspire
them to stay with it.
But the challenge that
they and others face
is that nobody wants to invest
in the Middle East today.
And I get it.
You know, there's
so much instability,
there's so much risk, and they
don't have a robust ecosystem
there.
And this seasoned
angels from here
aren't going to go and
do that, bridge the gap.
And that's where
TechWomen comes in.
We're a network of
more than 700 women
helping women from
the Middle East,
to Africa, to Central Asia.
And we help each other
overcome barriers
and we help our alumni make the
impact they feel is most needed
in their local community.
That's TechWomen.
We bring women from 21
countries to the Bay Area
for professional mentorship.
Beyond that, we
connect and empower
them with a network of women
who have the knowledge, skills,
and will to make things happen.
In those four short
weeks, the women
are exposed to innovative
ideas and technologies.
And even more importantly,
they meet positive role models
and other women leaders.
Those four weeks are
just the beginning,
and this is where
the impact begins.
While here, the women
collaborate with their country
cohorts to devise an
action plan to address
social and economic issues.
Our Jordanian
fellows, for example,
went back home and
developed a program
to support female graduates and
increase the number of women
in the workforce.
They, along with five
other action plan groups,
won a [INAUDIBLE] grant to
make those plans a reality.
These women are
the change agents
who know what their
community needs firsthand,
and they're taking
the bold steps
to make a lasting difference.
Well, challenges are global.
So is the power of
mentorship and our network.
We couldn't do it without
the support of companies
like Google, who take the
time, support, energy,
and inspiration, and
offer it to the mentors.
And it's what makes our
program a success today.
Silicon Valley has
long embraced a culture
of moving fast and taking leaps.
There's so much movement
toward greater diversity
and breaking cultural norms.
And we're shaping a movement.
And not only can
we set precedents,
but we have the impact
to change the globe.
The fact is, when women
are healthy and educated,
their children are
healthy and educated.
When women are empowered,
their families are empowered.
Stronger families means
stronger communities,
and it is our hope
for a better tomorrow.
Minimal amount of
time and effort,
through mentorship,
funding, networking,
and simply spreading the word
can make an invaluable impact
on one person, like Hannan
and Afnan, who went back
home and made a change.
Come visit our
booth to learn more.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]